[Applause]
so
there were grammys yesterday i didn't
realize until about after
it's so funny how little we care with
nothing else to do we don't even
remember grammy's
oscars is probably not going to give a
[ __ ] only reason i knew the grammys were
happening is because they were trying to
cancel bill
the only reason why yeah the only reason
like old billy [ __ ] tits came through
what's that that's his nickname that's
what he calls himself on stage does he
really
yeah oh my god dude i was like yo mark
why don't you just
special you ever heard that you never
heard that [ __ ] oh billy [ __ ] this old
billy redface
no we going at chappelle we going
what are you trying to do over here but
yeah so they i guess he was saying some
stuff akash showed us a couple videos
and it's so funny because he's just
being him
he couldn't care less dude he couldn't
care less and there is no audience i
guess it's all done
uh was it through streaming or something
yeah i guess so but he's
at some space some theater whatever and
it sounds like he's bombing because
there's no audience right but you can
hear the workers
laughing laughing yeah right it's like
an old episode of talk soup or something
like that so
he's clearly not bombing and if you're
watching at home you're laughing
but everybody on twitter that's just
like this woke social justice warrior
that doesn't even know who the [ __ ] bill
burr is
is going yeah see look what happens when
comedians tell
jokes about you know sensitive topics
you know it doesn't work out you're
bombing it's like no
the guy was [ __ ] murdering we're all
dying
laughing yeah it's also great because
having we took a car ride or billboard
after the patrice benefit yeah yeah
and he just is so in touch with his
funny yeah one of the most awkward car
rides i've ever seen
one of the well i mean you know you look
up to the guys so much
you know what i mean so it's like i
don't know i was just i admire this guy
i think he's so [ __ ] funny but at the
same time i'm you know trying to have a
conversation with him but
he's also so good at just doing the talk
it felt like i was on his podcast which
he does by himself so that's what it
felt like
yeah so and uh he was just i mean he was
just
one topic after another bang bang but i
didn't know if i was like
should we do this together or i just
throw up softballs i mean you could say
anything you could be
yeah what do you think about uh tampon
commercials yes yeah we get it
it sucks it up anybody wants yeah i mean
how often you need
to be told it soaks it up i think it
soaks it up i remember i was in the
green room and like he went on and on
for
like probably 20 minutes straight about
helicopters and this was right after
kobe pass
oh yeah no one got a word in and he was
just
yeah every factor yeah helicopters and
then putting jokes in between
like he had the whole thing broken down
because i i know that he loves
helicopter so when
he was in the green room for the patrice
thing i was just like maybe he's got
some interesting perspective on it and
stuff like that and dude he was
yeah yeah yeah it's [ __ ] cloudy
just don't take it up
i love it you see the clouds you don't
go
i love the guy who is himself all the
time
on stage it's just like i'm just doing
the same [ __ ] i always do yeah so i was
just in that car ride just like oh this
is the best just watching this happen
and that's what i thought the grand
mission was he's just he's being him
making himself laugh with the yeah he
he opens i haven't been able to find the
piano solo that happened before he went
on stage but he opens by going
and i'm am i the only one that wanted to
kill himself during that piano solo
[ __ ] now i don't know who did the
piano solo but that was the highlight of
their life
[Laughter]
right like they were like i'm fine mom
dad i'm finally performing
at the breakfast please watch and the
second you finish
bill burr stop there going hey that was
a suicidal piece of music right there
wasn't it
god dude then he [ __ ] up the winner's
name he's
he's presenting tropical latin album of
the year he's so funny not even a
[ __ ] distiller it's not a very
troubling
latin album haven't been in miami it's
all tropical latin the guy doesn't look
tropical at all
he looks like the hawaiian punch guy a
little bit
yeah he's a little red you know that's
that's as close as he is to tropical
oh my gosh so yeah um
so yeah it's just so funny when like
twitter thinks they can cancel somebody
that
you can't cancel somebody whose fans
love what they do yeah do you know what
i mean like
trump should have taught everybody that
like if what he does
in like uh what's up if what he does
like
hypes up his fan base if they love that
thing you can't cancel him for it
yeah and that's what bill was doing he
was doing him yeah so his fans
loved that he trashed the emmys while he
was hosting him so you can't in any way
cancel the guy for something that their
fans love the greatest
so good yeah it is steve it's funny
seeing everyone call him racist
like oh this guy is so racist what was
racist that's what i'm saying
on twitter everyone's like oh he's
racist that he got her name wrong that
he [ __ ] up all this [ __ ]
he [ __ ] up her name apologized i was
like he's like i'm accepting this award
on your behalf
yeah i'm sorry i butchered your name
that's it why is that racist
i don't know is it racist to get
someone's name wrong can you get
anything wrong anymore
i don't know can't we just be wrong and
her name is hard too what's her name
this is mark i'm not i don't know how to
say it i'm racist
i know you're racist you try to
pronounce it i will put it up
yeah pull it up let's see let's see if
we got it n i g
g
nobody knows and it doesn't matter right
i texted it to you
best tropical latin performer album i
think what a tropical land album who
cares
anyway you're not canceling bill burr he
couldn't give a [ __ ] i'm
so surprised that he was even at the
emmys yeah that was the saddest part
he's like why are you here you're better
than this
but what he said was interesting is like
the only reason i came oh yeah
because i thought i was going to meet
all these rock stars but you must have
known nobody's going to be there
i could see milburn not knowing also
yeah maybe he did yeah
these aging rock stars they're like 80
years old they've done every single drug
corona will take them out in a
[ __ ] split second and he still thinks
that they're going to show up to the
enemies
the one who wanted to meet some [ __ ]
random ass yeah richard dawkins or
something i was like isn't that like a
scientist
that's what i would get that's a stupid
name dude
that's stupid bro that's dumb dude don't
do that
don't do it natalia
yeah you think bill burr is going to be
able to pronounce that
do hold on if there's not an mc at the
beginning of his name also no need for
him this is another thing
you don't get practice oh yeah it's true
cause you don't know you don't know
who's gonna win uh
if that you knew who's gonna win you
could practice it but you don't know you
could practice all five but ain't nobody
wanna learn that many spanish names
there's a lot to remember it's too many
in the moment you can [ __ ] one up come
on bro
natalia la forte nah
you killed it yeah he did murder that
[ __ ] bro you're not racist yeah
um what else i think this is uh
comedians just doing this on purpose for
some clout oh before you had um
tracy morgan what are you doing
oh yeah
the winner is sal i mean so [ __ ]
that he didn't say [ __ ] that's literally
how he said it and like they start
clapping
i mean so like as they're fading out the
music
oh this is fun bro he's hating because
he wasn't in it
oh yeah that could be some hate try to
give him a spanish name
that's what it was it had the latin
album
what else we got going on man
yeah yeah yeah y'all got a stemi nah nah
i don't know if i can get it i don't
know how that [ __ ] works because i
didn't get this just goes to your bank
account i didn't do taxes for 2018 or
something do taxes
oh so you can't get any of this money i
don't [ __ ] know
you you can't get it you make too much
you might be able to get it maybe not
yeah i think you might you gotta put
dove on it bro we gotta go i think you
make too much we too rich over here
dove definitely found a way to get that
stimulated did you get that stemi you
know it
got him i'm charging you for the pool
house this month
that's why directly to me that's why
alex got the outfit bro he's trying to
look like he deserves it
yeah yeah yeah you gotta look like a
contractor or some [ __ ]
i'm doing labor i'm trying to sharpen
the [ __ ] i don't know what this
outfit is out
john i love it but can you what is the
deal with the upside down goggles like
what's the whole thing the 90s rap thing
when you're not
home you can dress in costume every
single day oh so this is a costume we're
acknowledging it
because miami i would never dress like
this son the hoodie to the shoes they
all match like everything's fine until
you go to the goggles yeah but the
goggles
because i ride a scooter and so i just
bought these and i was like oh [ __ ] i
got a little yellow in it let's just
rock it oh
okay so you built a whole outfit out of
it it's the money more problems look
yeah
and then i may sit at this yeah talking
about outfits do you have another shirt
nope
yo they're coming for you on jeans too
they're like yo akash got two pairs of
jeans
i got a black and a blue yeah and one
shirt
and the comments are wearing thin on the
shoes too at first everyone's like at
first i was like yo the shoes are fire
that's all i got and i underpacked yeah
he's leaning in went back twice
twice you couldn't pick one shirt to
bring back so you couldn't order a shirt
from amazon yeah
you've worn this shirt for sixty percent
of the episodes we've done since yeah
people think it's a rerun every time
like i'm not gonna watch it
yeah they probably think it's a [ __ ]
it's killing the numbers i don't dress
so goddamn
stupid they won't even turn into this
podcast i know i got new jeans coming
i'm waiting
is that the same undershirt too no no no
i bought new undershirts that's the only
part you said like a lego character you
just built with the shirt
comes off of you i think you got one
outfit for life
all the purchases i made are underwear
and socks and then the rest really yeah
it's a shame because he's looking good
like oh yeah i saw him walking in the
gym the other day bro he's got some
muscle i'm at the gym today too
you got the biceps yo honestly your face
is looking slimmer
i'm at the gym too much to buy new
no get your clothes on that [ __ ] bro
yeah you're right
don't take that [ __ ] man the fans still
shame this [ __ ] out of wearing
[Applause]
shorts
you